[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du skyco le magazine qui vous
raconte les aventures économiques du
territoire de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
nous sommes au Vélodrome national durant
les championnats du monde de cyclisme
sur piste qui se tiennent du 12 au 16
octobre c'est un événement qui permet de
faire une répétition générale en
perspective des Jeux olympiques de 2024
dans cet enceinte sportive connectée à
la 5G et oui nous allons vous faire
découvrir les coulisses de cette
expérience technologique menée par Nokia
et ses partenaires dans le cadre du
projet innovant Stadium Lab c'est au
programme de ce 47e numéro du skyco le
street recruting le nom de la dernière
opération de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
une initiative réalisée en partenariat
avec les entreprises du territoire
objectif les entreprises recrutent sur
la voie publique
durant les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste Nokia et ses
partenaires ont testé leurs solutions de
stade connecté en 5G une solution qui
permet d'améliorer l'expérience du
spectateur
xdmotion fait partie des partenaires de
Nokia spécialisés dans la captation
audiovisuelle aérienne la société basée
à Coignières teste ses caméras en vue
des Jeux olympiques de 2024
on commence le skyco avec une initiative
innovante pour recruter c'est le street
recruting le principe plusieurs
directeurs et directrices de ressources
humaines d'entreprises du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines sont allés
faire le recrutement directement dans la
rue c'était le 4 et 6 octobre dernier à
la fois à la gare de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux puis dans le
centre commercial de l'espace
Saint-Quentin Julien Leroy a suivi
Sabrina friac la responsable de l'agence
adéquate spécialisé dans le travail
temporaire regardez
bonjour Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
recrute si vous êtes intéressé on est
plusieurs sociétés aujourd'hui
regroupées ici de 50 ans en Yvelines
alors moi pour ma part je suis
responsable d'une agence de travail
temporaire pour le groupe
[Musique]
adéquatiques et c'est pas possible c'est
vraiment une première approche pour nous
présenter présenter les sociétés sur
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui
recherchent des profils et ensuite si
vraiment la candide la personne en face
de nous est intéressée et si nous même
le profil le profil peut correspondre à
ce qu'on recherche on les convoque un
entretien plus poussé au sein de notre
agence c'est intéressant parce qu'on
rencontre directement à la population et
on peut échanger sur leur problématique
pour charger du travail pour se rendre
au travail coup de personnes qui sont
déjà en poste mais qui cherchent à se
rapprocher de 50 ans en Yvelines donc
c'est la bonne occasion pour nous du
fait qu'on soit situé sur 50 Kevin de
leur proposer un emploi tout près de
chez eux pour éviter les transports et
les temps à rallonge pour aller
travailler
[Musique]
un bilan plutôt positif parce qu'on a eu
on a eu des candidats qui nous ont
appelé en agence qui a envoyé des CV et
on a envoyé quelques candidats aussi en
entretien chez certains de nos clients
donc si ça peut vous intéresser pour
vous pour une personne de votre
entourage n'hésitez pas à postuler ça se
passe sur 50 ans en Yvelines ok bon
courage au revoir monsieur
[Musique]
la première fois que 50 ans divine
organisent ce type d'opération sur le
terrain à la rencontre directe des
administrés des habitants avec des
entreprises pour leur parler d'emploi
essayer de les sensibiliser aux offres
qui existent
[Musique]
on a créé nouvellement ce qu'on appelle
une tasse qui force RH c'est-à-dire une
association de tous les DRH de nos
entreprises pour être à leur écoute et
essayer de répondre à leurs à leur
souhait et donc cette opération et la
conséquence directe de cette Task Force
RH qu'on a créé il y a maintenant un peu
plus d'Adam
il y a une tendance de fond dans toutes
nos structures liées à l'accompagnement
du retour vers l'emploi qui est d'aller
vers de pas attendre que les demandeurs
d'emploi viennent nous voir mais que ça
soit les structures les entreprises qui
aillent sur le terrain rencontrer
directement les demandeurs d'emploi
on a eu près de 2000 contacts sur ces
deux jours qu'on a des entreprises dans
le secteur du BTP dans le secteur de
l'intérim dans le secteur de l'industrie
dans le secteur bancaire
[Musique]
dans le cadre des Championnats du monde
de cyclisme sur piste au Vélodrome
national de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
Nokia multinationales spécialisé dans
les télécommunications et ses
partenaires du Stadium Lab sont
mobilisés ils testent leur solution
d'enceintes sportives connectées à
travers la 5G pour en parler nous sommes
avec Stefan Holbert bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors déjà qu'est-ce que c'est le
Stadium Labs
financée par le gouvernement dans le
cadre des projets d'innovation autour de
la 5G ou on va démontrer l'état d'usage
de la 5G pour améliorer l'expérience
spectateur mais également améliorer le
fonctionnement des opérations pour les
équipes opérationnelles et ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est qu'il y a une
multitude d'acteurs et exactement donc
aujourd'hui autour de Nokia leader
mondial de la 5G des réseaux privés on a
fédéré un certain nombre d'acteurs du
monde de l'audiovisuel qui capture de la
vidéo mais également de l'audio des
acteurs de l'application audiovisuelle
pour choisir ses prises de vue et
également une expérience eSport pour
avoir une immersion totale dans le monde
du cyclisme alors une enceinte sportive
connectée mais pourquoi pour quel usage
en fait comme je vous ai dit c'est
d'amener de nouvelles
pour les spectateurs dans la salle pour
pouvoir avoir des prises de vue
différentes
pour avoir des ambiances de son
dégradins du centre de piste en direct
et avoir une immersion totale avec ses
sportifs préférés c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui là le spectateurs qu'on
voit derrière nous ils peuvent regarder
sur leur smartphone des choses qu'on ne
peut pas forcément voir dans cette
position ici alors techniquement ils
peuvent le faire on a déployé un réseau
privé pour pouvoir capter l'ensemble des
pubs vidéo via des caméras sans fil des
des banques sont avec plusieurs
commentaires dans plusieurs langues et
également donc après sur un smartphone
de pouvoir choisir l'angle de vue le
commentaire qui nous intéresse par
rapport à ce qu'on a envie de vivre
comme expérience alors Stéphane olbert
quels sont les technologies utilisées
par Nokia pour permettre à 7 ans
enceinte sportive connectée de
fonctionner on déploie un réseau 5G
privé donc c'est un serveur qui
correspond à un réseau mobile ou les
opérateurs j'ai un des millions
d'abonnés et ici on gère quelques
milliers d'abonnés comme vous pouvez
voir sur sur la salle technique on
déploie ensuite des Smalls sels des
petites cellules on en a trois sur le
site puis qui font dans les ondes mini
Messi qui permettent d'accéder à des
très très haut débit pour de la télé à
4K 8k mais également des latences
faibles pour pouvoir piloter en temps
réel ces images et avoir cette pétition
et cette immersion totale et justement
on va aller voir juste après xD motion
mais pour conclure d'abord est-ce que
c'est une répétition générale pour les
Jeux Olympiques parce qu'on sait que
dans deux ans les Jeux Olympiques les
épreuves de cyclisme surpris se
tiendront ici c'est un cas réel on a des
acteurs industriels qui déploient des
solutions commerciales qui fonctionnent
ensemble c'est juste l'opportunité pour
les organitaires de grands événements de
se l'approprier et de faire que ces
événements soient une grande réussite
merci beaucoup Stéphane olbert je vous
en prie on va justement pour rejoindre
tout de suite
Benoît d'antan le dirigeant est
fondateur de xD motion le spécialiste de
la captation audiovisuelle innovante et
vous allez voir c'est extraordinaire ce
qui se passe ici
[Musique]
c'est une entreprise pour nous présente
plus dans le Sky Eco elle est basée à
Coignières c'est xdmotion et nous sommes
avec le dirigeant et fondateur de cette
entreprise Benoît Danton bonjour bonjour
Nicolas
alors voilà on est sur les Championnats
du monde de cyclisme sur piste vous êtes
à la maison ici ah oui on est à la
maison c'est chez nous on est première
fois que je vais aussi proche de chez
nous en tournage oui parce que je le
précise vous êtes habitué aux Jeux
Olympiques donc forcément vous voyagez
tout autour de la planète là aujourd'hui
on est sur une expérimentation liée à la
5G effectivement donc cette
expérimentation aujourd'hui est bien
particulière puisque la 5G nous apporte
en fait une nouvelle technologie bien
spécifique et les caméras qui ont été
installés vont apporter beaucoup
beaucoup de possibilités sur le
broadcast et aussi pour les fans qui
vont bientôt être aussi importants que
ce que l'on va voir sur la télévision
par rapport à leur projection privée
alors justement qu'est-ce que ça permet
alors aujourd'hui on a différents types
de caméras on a des caméras ce qu'on
appelle des remote caméra toutes simples
qui sont installés dans le stade qui
sont pilotés à distance déjà la 5G nous
apporte la fluidité une latence
extrêmement réduite et surtout une
grande qualité d'image donc beaucoup
beaucoup de Data qui passent dans un
réseau privé 5G qui est sur différentes
fréquences et ça permet effectivement
d'être pratiquement comme si on avait
une fibre reliée mais en fait on est en
transmission et puis on sait que vous
avez différents systèmes de captation
audiovisuel plus de votre les unes que
les autres avec qu'est-ce qui est
présent aujourd'hui lors de ces
championnats du monde alors on a essayé
de réfléchir aux user case notamment
pour Paris 2024 et les Jeux olympiques
de savoir quel serait les attentes
vis-à-vis des broadcasteurs et des
besoins donc nous avons d'abord des
têtes remote deux axes qui sont à chaque
extrémité du stade qui sont reliés à
travers le réseau donc piloter l'image
est transmise mais surtout on a fini
l'innovation importante on a rajouté de
la réalité augmentée d'ailleurs avec une
société de 50 ans qui nous a aidé pour
créer les graphismes du l'UCI donc
c'était images et captée enregistrée et
transmise enfin enregistrer diffusé en
live pardon et transmise donc ça c'est
le premier
user case le deuxième user case ça va
être donc une caméra de très haute
résolution 360 en 8k cette caméra 8k est
montée sur notre produit x fly qui est
un cablecam vertical et donc on a la
possibilité de pouvoir la piloter à
distance mais surtout de transmettre
cette image très haute résolution à
travers la 5G ce qui était impossible à
faire autrement avec une latence
extrêmement réduite dernière outil
aujourd'hui qui est un petit peu le
faire de lance sur le vélo drone c'est
que nous sommes en retransmission pour
Eurovision donc live au niveau
international avec des dizaines de
repreneurs et en partenariat donc avec
Eurovision et orange on a donc décidé de
mettre deux caméras cette fois sur le
système X fly cablecam une qui va servir
pour effectivement l'intégralité du live
et une deuxième innovante en 5G qui est
une caméra donc gyrostabilisée avec
c'est à dire que l'image est très stable
avec une caméra 360 degrés qui est
retransmise en direct sur l'application
de ranger 20 grâce à la 5G de Nokia et
c'est la caméra qu'on voit juste
derrière vous et c'est piloté ici c'est
piloter ici par les deux opérateurs
Maxime et épaules qui sont dessus en
train de travailler et Fernando aussi
c'est les trio qui travaillent pour
l'équipe et qui aujourd'hui font
fonctionner en live ce système qui est
retransmis dans le monde entier merci
avec grand plaisir c'est la fin de ce
numéro du skyco merci de l'avoir suivi
vous pouvez revoir cette émission en
replay sur l'application mobile ou sur
notre site internet à bientôt sur TV 78
[Musique]